now I was excited I mean that that
always excites me that um you know we
weren't pioneers we weren't the first
people to do it but it was probably the
first sort of high-profile person to do
this to any to any degree and the first
podcast we did I think we broke the
world record which back then was I think
250,000 downloads and of course now
we've had about 150 million and it just
kept growing and then when we started
charging for it we thought what can we
do this commercially and that was an
experiment also Carla just left his job
so well and when we got to about I think
was about we've had about 10 million
downloads I think Stephen Merchant said
can we just charge it quit the business
Miriam kicked dinner with yeah right um
but I never thought it would take off I
thought it would be ah I didn't think it
would be a fad I thought I'd lose
interest very quickly but it's it's um
it's the one thing I do that I think
that I could do forever you know I TV
shows early because you want to get out
when you're on top or you want to move
on to other things or it was always
meant to be finite like the office or
and you know stand-up shows come and go
you do them for awhile and you you
commit them to DVD or television then
you gotta write a new hour which is
which is fun as well and you know you
move around doing different things on on
radio but the podcast I could I look
forward to it I want to do one now I
want to go back and say to Carl and
Steve you know we're doing one more job
we're getting the band back together and
it's just it's just fun it's the thing
you do that's fun at the time and you
you don't care about the result because
you've had fun doing it and you just put
it up there to see you know which is the
opposite of everything else we do we're
so myself and Steven we put everything
into it and we craft it and we worry
about the salt results we worry about
the legacy and we know we've got this
thing in our head go and this is forever
this is forever we never say that we'll
do we like maniacs the last few days in
an edit I mean we're going you know take
two more frames and you know walking up
the cold sweat and go and take that joke
out whereas this is we go in there we
ramble for an hour we edit it down but
on the Internet
and it's out there forever and I wish I
could be that free with other things but
it's a different discipline a different
a different gene kicks in when you're
doing something like the office or or
extras or even stand up to a certain
degree stand-ups different again because
the discipline there is you write it and
you think of funny things you think of
that been said before that I really feel
passionate about that that I get a laugh
let's try it out and I and I get about
40-50 minutes written or you know in my
head a big bag of observations then you
work in your work it and ad-libbing
every night that 40 minutes becomes 70
but the the really interesting about it
your your meter your punch line your
ramblings and all that are chosen by the
audience you know I played to like
200,000 people in my last tour so after
those like hundred dates or whatever it
was evolution by natural selection those
audiences chose your best bits for you
it's almost like you didn't have to do
anything it was just like a come a coin
sorter it did it for you and that's
weird because by the end you get and
I've never done that I've never done art
by democracy they're only chosen their
favorite bits they're not they're not
giving me notes and so everything's got
a slightly different ambition discipline
raised on debt to everything you do and
and that's exciting I remember thinking
that when we write in the office that
I'd seen stand-ups try to crowbar in
their routine into a sitcom and they
might as well turn to camera and said I
think a weird stuff and it didn't work
and so everything's got you know a
different discipline
you